the actual show is it's just like you
know
it doesn't even ride the line of like
it's not like monster trucks where it's
like as for kids but like you can enjoy
this right it is
purely for children like do they
actually joust or no they do but the
jousting is so goofy like they like ride
up and they slow down and they just kind
of
you know because it's scripted our guy
our green knight let us know from the
get-go i'm not in this show very long
because they all kind of ride out and
they like hold their flags up in the air
the red and white knight
he comes out and that dude is turned up
you know he's like
going around the arena going crazy and
then our guy comes out the green knight
comes out and he's just like
i was kind of winking at our little
section here and then i'm like hey man
i'm i'm getting minimum effort right
here i got 10 grand on you right now
yeah yeah yeah straight up and he's just
kind of looking at the kids and he's
kind of just going like
whoo
and then i just turn to lean i'm like
he's going to die so quick
he was the first one to go they try to
really
build building you know they try to
build it up so the first hour it's like
a two-hour [ __ ] thing
and the first hour is them just bringing
out horses doing dumb ass tricks and you
don't feel good watching it you're just
watching a horse like do a wheelie
getting whipped on the ass and like
pulled on the neck and the guy's like
come on come on
that's just going
uh then all the kids are just around
with swords
and you're watching the horse like who's
this for
this sounds like hell oh dude and then
on top of that again the script it's so
like it's harder than game of thrones
it's like reading the actual book house
it sends one to you and
and they have this dude who's up there
with like a historically accurate voice
like he's the host and the queen you
could tell she don't give a [ __ ] like
she wants to quit and the guy is just
are these like budding actors that play
these roles how do you get involved why
would you ever do this so it gets to the
end and it made me think like there
needs to be a show about this like a
scripted show or something because like
there's clearly like a hierarchy and
then there's there's the one guy
who he's like the heel in the whole
thing and his whole storyline is the
host is actually from some house that
provided this warrior for the event and
then that guy thinks the host is soft
for putting on an event with a woman so
he has this whole like misogyny arc he
has like this speech where he's just
like
you take orders from a woman you've lost
your way i'm like this is a deep ass
concept yeah for like children for six
year olds yeah and so
the dude is like really into it he's
giving it his all i'm like did you just
like burn out like from high school
theater what's what happened yeah so
then the red and white knight that guy's
all hyped because he's like the hero
spoiler alert if you end up going to
you
medieval
times
the red and white knight comes back out
and they fight and then you know he
kills him or whatever or he defeats him
and then that's like the story okay and
that's it
i was so pissed
dessert at least a little bit of ice
cream with some caramel on top nice and
apparently the coffee is really good we
didn't read and risk it we had some
mixed reviews people were responding to
my story one person was like medieval
times are you nine
hilarious and then other people yo you
gotta try the coffee from there bro
you're right middle of
jesus [ __ ] christ is that a stroke
medieval wheatie will be people
i'm wondering like on a saturday night
is it turned up yeah is it like this
mostly adults and like are people
drinking like i would imagine this guy
probably right yeah so i think we just
got in with a bad crowd yeah i'm sure it
gets crazy that would be really funny to
do a show about like the cass oh cause
you know there's probably one of them
that stays in character like that takes
it too seriously probably to do the
speaking that's what i'm saying like
he's actually a knight yeah you know
he's like the guy who taught us how to
sword fight yeah he's full method like
even in the locker room he's like great
job uh gentleman in squires and shut the
[ __ ] up jerry
dude we're we're out we're out you don't
you don't just keep doing this yeah i
know our guy as soon as he goes into the
back room
that dude is cracking him open yeah
green night green knight yeah i know
he's getting quite drunk as [ __ ] out
there he's like whoo
i lost again yeah
doesn't that piss you off man no it's
great that's [ __ ] awesome i get to
sit back here and i get [ __ ] up let me
show you how the green knight dies i
have to send this too but listen to
alina's cackle cause this was like this
is when the action was starting our guys
first up they joust through like what
the [ __ ] is this and then it's this
[Music]
let me just let me run that back
you gotta [ __ ] send that i mean it's
that's really funny because like his his
reaction speed after he got hit he got
hit and then he jumped and went on his
back that's it's like
you know the dude is is tanked i do have
to shout out the red and white knight
from buena park
at the midday show on sunday because i
don't know if they rotate it literally
might be him actually wait wait do you
have one on tick tock he said he has a
huge tick tock account he's kind of like
the guy that noel was saying who's like
probably two oh no no so he played the
red and white this is
dude this is the guy this is timothy
chalamet
yeah this is
wait what the [ __ ]
okay wait hold oh that just changed that
just changed yeah what that just changed
it's a horny thing
no no no no no no no it's not but i see
why this guy was giving it so hard to
the crowd this guy's got 432 000
followers
and his name is the black and white
knight and it says knight at medieval
times california oh this is our oh my
god
play one of him like speaking like
answering a comment that one to the
right to the right of that
[Music]
no that music ain't copyrighted it
probably is dude wait so this is him
having a bad day
oh no i think i think he's playing the
green knight
so what what oh wait no did i go too far
not far what the [ __ ]
whoa
i'm just like mind blown that there's
like a niche for medieval times content
i just can't believe this dude has half
a million followers scroll down scroll
down go to the one to the right of that
yeah that one
i think i might have to take you up on
that offer
i may have a lot of questions
seeing as
i've never delivered a baby before yeah
i think i'm out i think
yo good episode
so i'm going to head back back down to
earth i think
no no it's not actually we're staying up
here
what
bro so
no no no no no no no no no no this
changes everything that [ __ ] i would
look over and it's just hitting me now i
would look over and the green knight
everyone else was at work green knights
just like looking out
just waiting and this [ __ ] is
like to the crowd like
you dude i'm so glad we're doing this
cause i almost forgot there's a part
where the knights have to hand out roses
and this [ __ ] was like really like
with the
like and i thought that whole thing was
odd because i'm like why are these grown
men giving like little four-year-olds
roses that's so [ __ ] weird okay and
you the green knight you could tell
there was like a he's trying to do it in
the most platonic way possible right you
know he kind of give a finger pistol
almost like
he's thinking about his michelob yeah
thinking about his two michelobs in the
fridge in the green room he's like just
[ __ ] running through the motions get
this done
this guy's like oh that that dude was
i'm gonna [ __ ]
oh mom
yeah
literally
he borderline was like
man i just i can't believe like this
makes so much sense i can't believe like
humanity's ability to like
sexualize [ __ ] anything
you know what i'm saying this is like a
show for children
and this guy somehow there's a thirst
trap edit of this dude
at medieval times this shouldn't exist
this video
this should not be sexy at all
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what is this one do we have to do this
one all right yeah click on that one
to the left yeah could you guys please
stop asking santa for a half latino
knight in shining armor with long dark
hair firm cheeks and mommy issues this
keeps happening
oh he did not
do that [ __ ]
oh brother this guy stinks
you know i don't want a player hate but
he must be [ __ ] a lot from medieval
times he definitely he definitely is
that's what i'm saying like got
renaissance bunnies that's what i'm
saying how how do we do this as a
humanity like
oh [ __ ] my thing is wouldn't you why not
just go do the real thing because the
real thing is out there
like being knight yeah that's what i'm
saying join a [ __ ]
look probably because you got to be a
squire and you got to go through all the
the [ __ ] yeah he just wants you to
pledge you know he just wants yeah he
wants to he went right to the starring
role yeah he wants to bone yeah no look
up go on youtube and type in m1 night
fight skip to the middle i'm sure it's
oh there's like an actual league for
this yeah where is this
um i don't know they do it in a number
of places but
m1 has hosted this a handful of times
again it's it's uh you know if you're
watching this on youtube it it probably
feels different for you because you've
never been in these shoes before yeah
yeah yeah yeah
something like this
it kind of just puts us right back in it
honestly totally like we can see
ourselves in this yeah
this is pretty goofy it is goofy i don't
know if just bring this back but like to
the death actually no i don't know if
this is a good example what do you think
look up like uh it's a good idea yeah no
i agree to the i mean that's mma and
like gladiator
yeah this is what i'm talking about yeah
this is sick
let's just skip to the middle bro
i mean it's still goofy but yeah this is
not as cool as i thought [ __ ] who is
horny at medieval times moms probably
yeah
it was something i just didn't even
didn't even factor into the equation
originally when you brought this up it
did when i saw your instagram stories
sex had nothing to do
with what you were doing this dude
dimmed me after the show and he goes hey
man that falcon was pretty entertaining
huh like being sarcastic there was a
moment where
i wanted to buy flags so we could just
[ __ ] around
[ __ ] but the falcon show came out the
dude's like hey man it's gonna be a
while so i can bring your card back
because no one's allowed to leave the
building when the falcons out
i'm like how shitty is this felt like
how shitty is this
that if someone just opens the door the
falcons would be like [ __ ] i'm out
dude thank god i've been trying to get
out of here i'm dipping thank you thank
you so much
this place is depressing as [ __ ] there's
some drunk dead they're like sir the
falcons out he's like get the [ __ ] out
of my way he just opens the door that
falcon is quick bro just imagine it's
just sliding
[ __ ] vertically yeah
and they're like [ __ ] we can't afford
another one of those [ __ ] things just
dead like 50k daps the dead on the way
yeah
appreciate you my god
you